okay
side by side if you want to yeah they um
they were considering look uh our side
and if you want to strike the nonline
all right let me let me call this
meeting to order all right all right
um
it's called the meeting to order the
committee conference on House Bill 534
we have the members from the house
myself representative Weiler
representative leishman representative
renzullo and representative Vale and I
see from the Senate we have Senator
avard Senator Pearl and seven Senator
Waters
that's what two T's can
okay we're looking at we have a side by
side presented from the researcher for
uh
the two versions of the bill that we're
meeting on
and
there's quite a difference
both in
the house version was two million five
and it did not lapse the Senate version
is 500 000 and it does lapse at the end
of the biennium
that anybody wants to suggest Senator
Pearl
so thank you um when we were when we had
this bill in finance I had spoken with
the bill sponsor about the reduction
down to five hundred thousand dollars
and he was fine with that at the time
uh my understanding is what he'd like us
to change is make it non-lapsing and I
guess I would propose that if the house
members would be willing to come to that
come to the 500 000 and make it
non-lapsing I think the Senate would be
okay
representative leishman
thanks Mr chairman uh as you may recall
this came out of the full finance
committee initially of not to pass at
all because there was some concern that
we do have another fund the water fund
that has
many many many millions of dollars in
and there's a feeling among division one
that recommended to the full finance
committee
that we not pass the legislation it did
pass on the house floor the finance
committee decision was overturned by
about five votes so there's a little
history there that uh
so I'm not in a good place or recommend
anything at this point because after our
review and full Finance it was a concern
that we were adding another fund that
already had a fund to support
groundwater
issues
also the
the
22 million 500 000 it's 500 it's a five
mil
because it went uh two and a half each
year each year okay so that is that is a
Mr chairman
that's Senator Waters thank you I serve
on the groundwater
um one I don't know if others do here as
well but
um it it is difficult for that fund and
I'm not sure that it can cover the kinds
of situations that are addressed here
particularly about private Wells and
drought for Agri for agricultural
purposes so that's why the Senate looked
favorably on it because
um you know serving on that committee I
I can see the argument that we need
something to address this kind of
particular circumstances and the Senate
go in to take this out of the 23.
um
budget so that we were not reopening the
current budget and that we've found as
Senator Pearl said that there was the
five hundred thousand dollars to support
that in the 23 budget and so that's why
we came to where we were in terms of the
question that representative leishman
raised and the source of the funding
oh
represent
representative Vale
thank you Mr chair
um
so for me
coming from the policy committee which
is resources Recreation and development
this is a humble sum of money however
I would be fine with making this a
non-lapsing fund and that's more
important to me than the appropriation
for many reasons one of which we heard
in testimony that the groundwater trust
fund is accepting applications that are
piecemeal for smaller projects that
they're not as prepared for and they
requested this Fund in order to be able
to address the wells running dry and
Wells that aren't working due to flood
conditions
Etc so for the for the committee
[Music]
for my position is really that we remove
the which under on page three at the top
shall not lapse until June 30th
in my mind it would say shall not lapse
thank you so much in other words
non-lapsing Forever non-lapsing at least
until there's any kind of legislation
legislation that breaks um this kind of
funding up so that we are addressing the
people that need it the most which is
homeowners that are taxpayers in every
town in in New Hampshire
my feeling was looking at what we've
done with the side by side even but this
needs new legislation
that this doesn't cover what I think we
all
wanted
collectively uh
both as Senator Waters said that that
committee he serves on
would like more money to to get some
things done
most of this money would come in a
disaster which is
something that comes along a little
later when we see available money and
maybe it's not it's available without
legislation very specifically what I was
um looking at it I thought there were a
lot of loose ends it it says poor people
or low-income people who are they they
should be defined uh you're going to
leave all this up to rule making
um
you know and
and that's that's what I I thought that
this needed new legislation rather than
what's here
and I'm
I'm not ready to move on with this
at least that's my opinion I think
incomplete things that I think it needs
a new bill that could come next year
because since we're not under any
emergency now
the haste to have this passed it's not
not there in my mind
Mr chair yes I may
we're not really here to have a policy
discussion at this point we're here to
discuss the differences between the two
bills right I understand there may be
some tension about the policy in general
but it did pass the house
the uh the real thing that we're here to
discuss is the money and the and the
effective date and you know in the
things that are in the last two
paragraphs at least that's my
understanding of what we should really
be having a conversation here about
I guess is there an objection from the
house to the
moving down to the 500 000 from the 2.5
and the date change that's really what
well
you've been affected it's not in the
budget by taking it out of 2023. if you
haven't really included it in the 24-25
of the funds that would have been in
that
so it's a big change from
from what we did in the house
which is difficult to swallow
so
question
uh if this if we if we remove the
if we if we change it back to a
non-lapse that means that money stays
there forever right or except for
that instance uh well that first you
well I think
disaster in order to go for that amount
of money right or to go for that small
amount of and but also it says that the
uh the Des has access to that money to
pay for
itself well if it sits there for a
certain length of time
concerned about
this is a direct giveaway
yeah it was funding uh there's in most
of the time you see in these type of
there is a
issues around Mountain loans things to
be able to get people give people a
skin in the game
and SEC and also it it didn't come up
and it'll take responsibility for that
during uh the house discussions
uh issues around well the wells that
were that in the previous attempt at
doing this uh
they they were
they had this there were people going to
Des and getting Wells done were these
uh Doug Wells
that that
which are fairly inexpensive
were they changed were they were they
were they changed to drilled Wells uh
uh that are not inexpensive right uh so
there's a big big difference and because
and also in Doug Wells tend to tend to
go dry all in in the summit
uh whereas to drilled Wells are not Mr
chair do you mind if we could just
is this your office okay absolutely
so uh
um thank you and uh it uh we're probably
gonna just hold to our the Senate
position which I know is not agreeable
to you folks so could we at least get a
commitment to the next session that we
could work on this issue
I'm sure that within his committee that
will be and it'll come to division one
but I think on this bill we agree to
disagree okay yeah
but
in an agreeable manner in an agreeable
manner
because we see it as an area that
perhaps can need some legislation but
not what we see before us all right well
we'll be happy to work with you next
session
always thank you